I'm coming up on Five Years on the lion
diet can you believe that five years of
only eating beef lamb bison salt and
water with the occasional vodka slash
bourbon I'll get into that later as many
of you guys know I came across this diet
out of desperation when I had come off
of psychiatric medications trying to get
my depression under control and my
juvenile idiopathic arthritis that left
me with a hip and ankle replacement at
17 under control because the medical
system was not doing it for me so I
stopped taking all my medication after I
went on the paleo diet when I was 23
very restrictive paleo diet no not
Starry eggs very limited fruit mostly
meat and greens that got rid of all my
symptoms until I came off of psychiatric
medications way too quickly I cold
turkey stopped taking antidepressants
after being medicated from the age of 12
to 23. that was horrific I didn't even
know I was an antidepressant withdrawal
for a number of years until my dad
experienced the same thing thing and
that's what led me to the lion diet and
I've been on the lion diet since
December 2017 to keep my autoimmune
disorder under control in remission I do
not take any medication and I have no
arthritic symptoms and to keep my
psychiatric conditions in remission
because I was extremely extremely
extremely depressed I had OCD symptoms
was diagnosed with bipolar and I was on
a lot of different medications and I was
absolutely miserable and I'm medication
free I'm no longer an antidepressant
withdrawal and I attribute almost all of
My Success to the lion diet so if people
are interested in it I have a ton of
free information up at liondiet.com I
have recipes you can kind of look into
my blog to see how I got to where I am
now I have an FAQ a very extensive FAQ
on there to help people start the diet I
also have a couple of Facebook groups
don't eat that for kind of elimination
diets health-minded people and the lion
diet for people who are specifically on
this diet who need a group with people
who aren't going to judge them while
they're doing all beef all lamb all
bison which can elicit some strange
stares and remarks
[Music]